[Musique]
ce soir de semaine pressées pour
charline et sofia c'est un peu la fête
la fête de la croquer c'est un bon
dépanneur deux soirs de semaine pressées
pour l'ensemble des familles je pense de
façon générale c'est très facile à
cuisiner et enfin côté agréable de
pouvoir passer avec ses doigts
de poulet pané effet encore très grande
on parle d'une bonne quarantaine de
produits qui sont en au congélateur
d'épicerie en ce moment ronde longue ou
en forme amusante d'animaux l'épicerie
on a choisi 13 parmi les plus populaires
saint-hubert flamingo compliments choix
du président jane's sélection et mépris
la base c'est le même produit dont parle
de poulet de viande de poitrine de
poulet formé de différentes façons
ce qui les distingue vraiment c'est le
degré de transformation de la viande
si vous voyez le mot filet de poitrine
morceaux de poitrine ce sont des
indications qu'on est sur du muscle
entier parce que ce sont des termes qui
sont contrôlés seulement deux produits
parmi nos échantillons contenaient des
morceaux de poitrine entière tous les
autres sont faits d'une préparation à
base de viande blanche
généralement on retrouve le terme
escalopes est sûr ceci à notre groupe où
on a de la viande qui a été caché et
formés pour plusieurs de ses produits
lors il ya d'autres types de protéines
qui ont été ajoutés pour la plupart on
parle de protéines de soya que vous
allez voir indiqué comme isolats de
protéines de soya qui est heures dans le
fond un concentré c'est un ingrédient le
sert à toutes sortes de choses notamment
à allier la viande et à garder à
stabiliser le tout pour que sa garde sa
forme entre le gel et le dégel mais
aussi évidemment ça joue sur la teneur
finale en protéines dont le donc l'étau
noir total peuvent être correct mais si
on l'isolé de septembre les protéines
qui vient vraiment de la viande
il ya clairement une différence entre
les produits plus musqué ceux qui ne le
sont pas
dans ce type de croquettes on retrouve
donc moins de protéines de poulet les
produits qui sont plaints muscles qu'on
parle de 18 à 20 % de protéines de
viande alors que ceux qui sont hachées
et reformer on est plutôt autour de 13 à
15% malgré les apparences presque toutes
les croquettes sont crus dieu une pré
cuisson qui a été fait en friture pour
l'extérieur
en fait pour la chapelure pour que tout
ça se tiennent puis lui donnait déjà une
couleur un peu d'eau ritz et n'est
vraiment pas depuis son bar en bar au
contraire dans c'est extrêmement
important de prendre le temps de cuire
les produits quelqu'un d'ikea l'arrière
d'avoir pour s'assurer pour chose que le
produit soit bon et finalement ça est
bien meilleur mais surtout de pas être
malade
le plus grand risque en fait c'est la
contamination à la salmonelle
j'ai onze chats pour connaître la
quantité de viande et de panure nous
avons demandé au chef enseignant richard
trottier et à deux de ses étudiants de
décortiquer dont produits finis je
pensais que je m'attendais à plus donc
on a vu dans l'est
l'été ce qu'on a fait qu'aller vers
certaines marques qui avait 1 50% child
donc chaussé vraiment biais les produits
avec les ratios les plus équilibrés son
choix du président poitrine et pépites
flamingo pépites et pépites xo xo mais
pour yves prime croquettes sélection
lanières de poulet et saint-hubert
croquettes et filets de poitrine et je
dirais là où le bât blesse pour cette
catégorie là c'est au niveau des
matières grasses et le câble ce n'est
pas du tout la viande parce que comme on
a de la viande blanche de poitrine de
poulet ce une viande qui est assez
maigre et en gros total et en gras
saturés par contre au niveau de la
panure non seulement la panure en
contient dans sa composition mais en
plus le produit était free avant qu'on
vous le vendre pour bar en bar mais
suffisamment pour que la panne heures et
absorber de l'huile plus de la moitié de
nos échantillons contient entre 13 et 16
grammes de matière grasse par portion et
on peut s'y attendre ce sont également
des produits très salés y en a deux qui
sortait vraiment du lot
significativement plus salée que les
autres qui sont deux produits jane's ce
qui est dommage j'ai envie de dire parce
que c'est parmi ceux pour lesquels la
liste d'ingrédients et la plus cinglé
mais ils sont de loin les plus salés
avec 1 500 mg de sodium par portion
à l'opposé nos moins salée étaient des
pépites de choix du président et les
pépites en forme
xo xo sans gluten de flamming bout qui
avaient respectivement 220 et 240 mg de
sodium on comprend que l'écart entre le
moyen le plus à l'est est quand même
substantielle des écarts de sodium mais
aussi de prix on passe facilement du
simple au double dans les 13
échantillons qu'on a évalué à mes yeux
le meilleur choix ce sont les filets
poitrine de poulet le choix du président
non seulement parce qu'on a à faire un
produit qui fait de muscles entier la
teneur en matières grasses est assez
faibles on est à 1 7 gramme total ce qui
est tout à fait raisonnable sodium 3 150
mg pas excessif non plus et une liste
d'ingrédients relativement simple ma
grande déception j'oserais dire et
auprès de nos p'tites pépées tu es en
forme d'animaux de saint-hubert qui est
un produit qui existe depuis très
longtemps
très apprécié mais malheureusement qui
est non seulement très salée surtout
pour un produit pour enfants mais qui
tous est très grand et malheureusement
le plus gros de tous nos échantillons de
tout montrait échantillons on parle de
16 grammes de matière grasse par portion
de 50 et deux fois plus gras que la
version pour adultes et aussi les plus
sucrées avec 6 g par portion
et ce avant même de les avoir trempé
dans une sauce sucrée
qu'est-ce qu'on fait que cette catégorie
de produits là on en mange jamais où
c'est clair que c'est des produits qui
sont pratiques ses clacs et les produits
qui sont agréables à manger ça devrait
quand même de marc est un produit plutôt
occasionnels et je pense qu'il surtout à
retenir c'est que ce genre de produit
l'eau ne devrait pour remplacer
complètement la consommation de viande
fraîche donc bons produits d'occasion
pour se faire plaisir
[Musique]